I don't treat cancer. I don't treat cancer. I'm not a healer.
So I've got to be dancing around you with a bit of sense or something like that.
I'm just going to be leading you to the right direction. Your body's not a healer.
Understand, by trading through a forever's and a integrative approach,
be that, you know, let's look at what's best for the patient.
That one's best for the doctor. Don't fit them into your goals.
You know, you fit the goal that's going to be best around them.
So, if that cancer trading alert a whole bunch of different approaches,
then you're just out of your tail off to alert as many different things you can do
to what's going to be best for that patient.
Here's a picture of President Vicki Biden in the Cancer Act in 1971.
We're going to fight this war on cancer.
You see the picture of Tybanne disease.
What do you point that term, the war on cancer?
At that time, what is what Americans got to do?
We are doctors really well in this war at home.
So, what is cancer?
So, this is what you have to explain to all patients.
Because I have patients, like Lonnie said,
stage 4 cancer, they've been through two years of treatment,
and they don't even know what cancer is.
So, I say, do you understand what cancer is?
I don't tell me. That's what they usually say.
So, cancer isn't some disease that's fallen on you
or something that you caught.
So, cancer is your normal cells that are reproducing too rapidly.
So, the way I explain it to a patient is that,
okay, here's your prostate cell.
Noremalea prostate cell will replicate itself
whatever 8 weeks prostate cell,
and then the old cell will die.
That's called normal apoptosis or normal cell death.
Program cell death.
When that old cell doesn't die,
and it starts replicated, replicated, replicated,
that's called cancer.
And the more rapid it replicates,
it doesn't replicate a perfect DNA.
And that's what cancer is.
And it starts growing out of control.
Believe it, we all have that going on inside of us,
every one of us.
You wouldn't be able to diagnose it even with the best instrumentation
until it's over a million cells.
So, that's happening all the time.
When it gets out of control,
let's say it's at 100,000 cells,
that's going to tee off your TH1 immune system.
That's going to get in there and go,
wow, we have it in there.
So, four of the particle there,
it's going to turn on the lymphocytes
and the TH1 cytokines to go and attack that thing.
This is part of the problem with a lot of cancer patients.
They are TH2-dominant,
so they will go back to autoimmune understanding.
So, what's the autoimmune issue?
So, you have a TH1-TH2 system.
You're either for your autoimmune.
You have a hyper-dominant,
a TH1 sign, or a hyper-dominant,
a TH2 sign.
If you have a hyper-dominant,
a TH1 sign, the chance of you getting cancer is going to be less.
The chance that you're going to have a lot of tissue destruction
in the big miserable because of the TH1 autoimmune
is going to be hot.
Right?
If you're TH2-dominant, autoimmune.
And most of the time,
you guys done autoimmune, or, right?
These are people who are self-clinical.
They've not been properly diagnosed.
So, they're TH2-dominant,
even slightly TH2-dominant.
They're TH1.
The cytokines are going to be in the pits.
They're not going to be able to find off cancer cells.
That's what's supposed to clean this up.
There's other things.
Each cell on the membrane has millions of different, different,
uh, uh, what do you call it?
Receptors.
Other cell membrane.
And some of them are specifically for program cell death.
So, that's important too.
With the menics,
with the MDs talk about a cure.
When a college talks about a cure for cancer,
that means that you survived five years past
the initial data diagnosis.
Do you guys know that?
And so, if you died the next day,
you're still listed as cured.
So, oh yeah, we cured him if he was cured.
Well, he's dead.
He died of the cancer.
Yeah, but he lived five years.
So, he's cured.
I understand.
That's the whole fallacy of what we really want to get
early diagnosed with these.
Why?
So, then our five years time clock starts earlier, right?
Because really, we don't have any better treatment for it.
But at least we'll show better statistic.
So, you do not talk about cure.
Okay?
I don't even...
I tell my patients,
okay, we're not going to talk about cure.
We all have cancer in growing in sus right now.
So, we'll explain that.
So, you're not cured of cancer.
Your body is either correctly managing it
or it's not correctly managing it.
So, all we're going to do is try to do everything we can
to get your body to correctly manage this cancer state
so that you're not dying out of it.
That's the whole purpose.
We're turning you to a chronic disorder
that you're going to correctly manage.
Coming from a Christian perspective,
how do I know that they shouldn't do the keyboard?
You can't argue with the fact that some people have been,
you know, had a great success with the keyboard with radiation.
You can't argue with that fact
and to sit to...
So, my position,
if you listen to my webinars or my radio shows and stuff,
I'm very strong in that.
You do not take a dog manic approach to healthcare.
So, I'll hit that really hard today
and by that, I mean,
you don't take an approach that,
oh, chiropractic, cures everything,
everybody just needs to get adjusted
and it's going to cure everything.
Well, obviously, you're probably not in that paradigm.
But we can easily get in the paradigm
that all keyboard medicine and ecology
when you're talking about cancer is bad.
And even though I get a bad shit like crazy this weekend,
it's not all bad.
And there's a purpose and a place for everything.
Plus, coming from a Christian perspective,
I believe that, you know,
if I got cancer,
so this is what I do tell people.
If I got cancer, this is what I would do.
And first thing I do is go,
okay, Lord, what's going on here?
What's your purpose in being in cancer?
Because you're sovereign and you allowed me to get cancer.
Baby, it's to go through chemo and radiation
and to witness to some key motors.
I have a willing to do that.
That's my perspective.
You got to look at, okay, God,
this is in my life for a reason.
Is there something to learn from this?
Do I have to grow from this?
I know I'm not supposed to just do nothing.
So is this the right way to go?
So what I tell patients, I say,
we're all going to die.
Some people are going to die from cancer,
and some people are going to walk across the street
if I truck.
It doesn't need, you know, both ways,
before you walk across the street.
Right?
Because we're all going to die,
so it's going to walk across the street.
It doesn't need, you know,
trying everything so you don't die of cancer.
Right?
You should try everything,
but you really got to know
that this is what you want to do.
I'll tell you, every single patient
that walks in by office leaves
the exact same thing in some way,
shape or format.
This was the only place
that they gave us any hope.
And because my philosophy is,
you came to me for, you know,
one of three reasons,
either to hear about God,
and I'll tell you,
to get better,
or both.
That's it.
That's the only three reasons.
God said to you.
So, oh, you're already a believer?
Great.
Then you're here to get better.
So let's get you better.
That's the bottom line.
In my office, so that's just my tape,
my philosophy,
with what you want.
But they're not in it all the way.
And they're not in it, you know,
that I got to take responsibility
for this.
My body is doing this.
And I got to fix why my body is doing this.
And clear up the environment.
So my body can heal.
That's it.
That's making putting that
responsibility on me to heal them.
That's really super important.
How do you tell a person,
you know, whether they should do the
keyboard or not?
That's how I tell them.
I don't know whether you should.
You've got to really pray about that.
You've got to figure that out yourself.
But if you do do the keyboard,
then you've got to be really serious
about everything that I tell you,
because we've got to get it out of you.
And if you don't do the keyboard,
then you've got to be really serious
about everything that I tell you,
because we've got to get your body
working and fixing this thing.
So either way,
you've got to be in it all the way.
But some things that you should know
about the keyboard therapy
is how they give it.
So there's a junk-dent
keyboard therapy.
This is some terms that you're going to hear.
That's keyboard therapy given to destroy
leftover microscopic cells.
So that means they already did surgery on it.
So we're going to do a junk-dent
keyboard therapy after surgery.
We think we got it.
We took out the whole breast,
the prostate, whatever.
But then we're going to do a junk-dent
keyboard therapy.
Why are we doing that?
Because they're still tumor cells.
That's honest.
There is still tumor cells, right?
But like I already stated,
so there's still tumor cells there.
There's stem cells
and circulated tumor cells.
Are they rapidly reproducing
at this point in time?
No.
What does keyboard therapy kill?
Rapidly reproducing cells.
That's all keyboard therapy targets.
It's rapidly reproducing cells.
That's why it destroys your immune system.
You're going to hear that a lot.
You're going to hear first-line keyboard.
First-line keyboard is the keyboard therapy
that has through research studies,
yeah, who did the research?
And clinical trials have been determined
to have the best probability of treating a given cancer.
So first-line keyboard therapy means
this is what the Merck manual says,
or this is what the pharmaceutical company said
to give prostate cancer.
That's first-line keyboard therapy.
Second-line keyboard therapy
is that it's given if a disease
is not responding to the first-line keyboard therapy.
So it's like,
this is the practice of oncology.
So this is what we're supposed to do first.
If it doesn't help, then this is what we do next.
Oh, and it didn't help at all.
So we're going to give palliative keyboard therapy.
Does that even make sense?
We're just going to give you something to make you feel better.
Did it make you feel better?
Or the first time?
We're going to give it to you.
Oh, boy.
So the other thing you got to know about keyboard therapy
is that these people will get keyboard brain.
So like brain fog of fibromyalgia,
you've damaged what are some other rapidly reproducing cells?
Well, your microglial cells can be.
So you're going to damage microglial cells.
They're going to have a lot of inflammation in the brain.
So you got to deal with that.
That's where your brain-based therapy is going to come in big time.
So you could help these people,
you know, with neuroplasticity,
work with their brain-based therapy, get their brains back.
Okay, so this is another thing that I think is important to know is,
how do you give keyboard?
There's oral keyboard medications that are out there.
So actually, my patient with brain cancer
said she refused the intravenous keyboard therapy,
then they said, oh, instead we'll give you this.
Well, she's a pretty smart lady.
She went and looked at that, but she actually brought in the keyboard,
the pills that she gave them to me.
She said, I'm not using this.
Do you want these to test people on it?
You know, I said, sure, I had it by my office front.
I didn't really want that stuff in my office.
This is such poison.
I don't remember how I got rid of it.
I don't know how I got rid of it.
I can't remember how I got rid of that stuff.
Somecutaneous injections,
intramuscular chemo,
most of it's going to be oral chemo or intravenous chemo.
And the thing that they're going to talk about
is they're going to get a pick line put in.
So the patients are going to say,
I got to go get a pick line put in,
or I got to go get a porta-cath put in.
Lots of times they'll interchange those.
Even though it is a porta-cath, it's a cath tube.
They'll get it up here in the chest.
That they're going to go in and they have that permanently done
so that when they go in,
they don't have to go find an artery or an abade
and inject it in that way.
Because they're sitting there for half an hour.
And if you want some motivation to do cancer care for patients,
you should just go to the oncology department
of your local hospital and walk in there.
It's like a mortuary.
People sitting there getting their chemo treatments.
It's just horrific.
So that's why they put these catheter things in there
so that all they have to do is go and connect them
and they're done.
You know it's like if they spill any chemo,
it's like a major chemo-toxic spill
that they have to have teams
come in and clean it up and stuff.
So different agents.
Does chemotherapy significantly increase
patient survival rates?
So let's look at some study.
Here was a study from the Journal of Clinical and Collegy
December 2004 looking at contribution of cytotoxic
chemotherapy to the five-year survival rate
and adult malignancies.
They can't do test-done kids.
They're just given the same drugs,
but they can't do test-done them.
So let's look at way down here.
1989 to 1994.
What's the five-year survival rate of all stages
of colon and rectal cancer?
Five-year survival rate is 63%.
What is it now?
All the new drugs that they have.
65%.
It hasn't changed.
So don't believe when, you know,
this is where helping educate your patients about
what they're getting when they tell you,
oh, my doctor said he's going to use this new
chemotherapy on you.
You could even say, what is it?
Well, let's look it up.
Wow, that was first introduced in 1984.
He said it's a new chemotherapy.
Really, when I learned in my classes,
there hasn't been a new chemotherapy introduced
since chemotherapy was introduced,
except that it's just a tweaked old model.
And part of the reason is,
it's way too expensive to bring any new drug to market.
I end my book.
If you want to take time,
you look at some of the studies that I've asked it
and some of the other new chemotherapy drugs
that were held to me,
a huge high standard that was going to cure breast cancer
and stuff.
And then after it's been out for five years,
and you look at the survival rates,
it hasn't changed anything that affected
and increased the cause,
an increased uterine cancer in these women
that have taken it over a year.
Unbelievable.
And yet, they still sell this stuff.
Matter of fact, Avastin was pulled from the market
for several months and then they pushed.
How did that happen?
Some political thing.
They were with us studies, Kimo.
On any breast cancer,
who's sitting there in shock,
that they just got diagnosed with breast cancer,
and they're pushed into chemo the next day.
So, chemo contribution to five-year survival rate,
increase in cancers studied.
They did two studies,
one in Australia and one in the US.
So,
chemo's contribution.
What chemo helped a person
increase their five-year survival rate
in Australia was only 2.3% increase.
2.1% increase in the US,
of the people studied.
The median survival increase in lung cancer
was only two months.
Overall, survival benefit of less than five percent
has been achieved in breast cancer,
colon and neck cancers.
So, when they say,
well, we have a five-year survival rate,
let's go back,
of 65%.
Well, really?
How much of it was due to the chemo?
How much was it due to your care?
That's was my question to this oncologist,
who's going to put this little kid through,
whole skull and whole spine radiation,
and chemotherapy with three chemotherapy drugs,
including cisplatin,
which is an adult horrible chemotherapy drug.
We have a 63% survival rate.
Yeah? How many would have survived
if you didn't?
1% is if you didn't do it.
Like I said, 0.
Well, how many were in that study?
Well, we didn't have anybody that didn't do it.
These are the five-year numbers that they go off of.
It's crazy.
So, they did a study on how much does that increase the survival rate?
It doesn't really do anything.
Cancer is in which chemo might help the survival rate.
That's the Hodgkins and Dodge Hodgkins.
Ovarian, testicular.
We added ovarian cancer patients.
Oh, my gosh.
She was killed by the chemo.
It was horrible. She was only like 23 years old.
You remember her?
She said her women very office.
Oh, my gosh.
Beautiful young lady.
It's just horrible.
Belly swalled out to here and looked like she was eight months pregnant.
Radiation therapy.
There's a whole bunch of new advances in radiation therapy.
You guys have heard of the cyberdife, right?
Where this is actually,
I think it's the cyberdife.
There's a lot of different names for it.
All of it is different radiological companies that came out with a little bit different looking version.
It all does the same thing.
Circulates around the patient to try to pinpoint the accuracy of the radiation to one point.
It makes a lot of sense.
You're still getting just as much damage to the brain.
And again, it goes back to,
well, I guess that makes sense.
How you're going to cure cancer is to get rid of those rapidly reproducing cells by destroying them.
Understand.
This is the way I talk to patients.
Well, I guess that makes sense.
But why did the cancer come there in the first place?
That's the way you want to talk to patients.
Oh, let's think about this.
Let's reason together here.
Why did you get it in the first place?
Well, they said if we do the cyberdife,
that would just remove the cancer, that would cut.
Oh, okay.
How did it start?
Well, they didn't talk about that.
Do you think we should?
Yeah, well, you think it'd be a good idea?
Do you think it'd be a good idea?
So you just try to reason with your patients.
You think.
This is how I give classes to them.
Do you think it'd be a good idea to find out
the reason why that thing is there?
Same thing when you're talking about thyroid conditions,
autoimmune conditions.
Huh.
We have autoimmune thyroid.
So your immune system is attacking the thyroid.
Do you think it'd be a good idea to find out
why the immune system is attacking the thyroid?
And if we could find out why,
and we could get rid of the reason why,
and the immune system would stop attacking the thyroid?
Would that be a good idea?
Yeah.
Let me go ahead.
Well, why don't we do that then?
Okay.
Can we?
Same thing with cancer.
Wouldn't it be a good idea if we fixed the reason why
the cancer started in the first place?
Maybe we do need to cut it out.
Maybe we do need to chemo-bomb it.
Maybe we do need to radiate it.
But shouldn't we fix the reason why it's there?
Because do you think if we don't fix the reason why it's there
that could come back?
I'm just saying.
One of my mentors, Dr. Mark Rosenberg,
who practices at Mocha Raton, Florida,
he's an MD cancer researcher.
He was actually the head of,
I think it was John Hopkins,
ER department for 10 years,
and his mom got cancer,
and she died,
and he was like,
I'm changing.
He just completely changed his whole life,
and he just went into cancer research,
and he's just into all sorts of alternative things.
He does do.
Did you ever get a hold of him?
He does do some low-dose chemo.
And there's another chemo that's not even legal
in the United States.
It's called insulin-potentiated chemo.
It's unbelievable.
It's not legal.
What's that unbelievable?
Because it's cheap.
So you do very, very low-dose chemo
with a shot of insulin, I think,
30 minutes or 60 minutes right before the chemo.
Insulin, ever chemo,
or cancer feeds off glucose.
You shoot it with insulin.
It's going to go right to the cancer,
so it just drags the chemo right to the cancer.
One of my friends in the cancer program,
he's working at the Philippines
doing this work with some lazy results, too.
But it just drags the chemo right to the cancer.
But it's against the law.
The United States.
Figure that.
Unbelievable.
But Dr. Mark Rosenberg,
he's got some ties into a clinic in a,
I don't know, a newer Central America or something like that.
He does some work out of there, too,
because he's like, well, any time they could drop the bomb,
and I'll lose my medical license here.
So he's just protecting himself that way.
You know what I'm saying?
Because he still does,
he does some off-label drugs,
and he does some low-dose chemo.
He wants to do that.
And so if he lost his medical license,
he couldn't do that anymore.
Whereas if I lost my carpractic license,
I could be an antropath.
So or something like that.
I could be a nutritional counselor.
He can't do that because he's doing some events.
Cancer surgery decreases perioperative immunity.
So really important.
So not only does cancer surgery spread cancer cells,
number three,
but it also decreases your immune system.
So what do you need to fight cancer?
Your immune system.
So this is how I tie cancer.
And even to my autoimmune talks,
is that you need a TH1 system, a TH2 system.
And when you,
this is how the medical system takes care of autoimmune patients.
So let's say a person's TH1 dominant autoimmune,
TH2 system is suppressed.
And this is causing all sorts of cytokine production,
all sorts of inflammation.
It's killing your thyroid, destroying your muscles,
or wherever the autoimmune attack is.
Right?
So what is the medical approach?
What is it?
Well, suppressed the immune system.
So what does it do?
Does it do this?
No.
It does this.
And I say,
the last time I checked,
we still need an immune system.
What else does your immune system do?
It kills cancer cells.
So a person that's on prednisone,
why is it that they have an increased risk of cancer?
Because you just suppressed the immune system.
It's funny how all the cancer treatments suppress the immune system.
All the medical cancer treatments suppress the immune system.
It's counter-think here.
What's going on here?
Doesn't make any sense.
You understand?
So you tie this ear.
You tie these things together.
They're not separate.
Almost every cancer patient is an autoimmune patient.
They're TH2 dominant autoimmune.
Any time subclinical.
They don't even know.
They are.
Surgery, including biopsies,
does spread cancer cells.
Especially if the cancer is already walled off.
Now you just broke that wall and you got circulated tumor cells.
Removal of tumor growth inhibition factors.
There's growth inhibition factors in your body too,
trying to keep it at bay.
Now you remove the tumor.
You just disrupted all of that.
And now you got an injury site.
You got inflammatory cytokines coming.
You got all this inflammation coming.
That is, you know,
to bring in epithelial cells,
to heal the scar tissue that's going to heal that injured site.
You just did surgery.
That didn't help the maloo at all, right?
Cancer surgery increases parrapper to free radical generation.
I don't know the physiology of that,
but that was a study that was done.
The type of anesthesia may influence cancer growth and metastasis.
Parrioperative integrative measures seem not to be concerned at all.
Institutions concerned at all basically about this,
even if you show them scientific proof.
Typically they're saying, well, it's better to go in there
so we can get a type of this cancer
and find out exactly what's going on.
Sometimes, again, this is the question you ask.
Should I do a biopsy?
Well, isn't it going to change the way you treat the patient?
If it's going to change drastically,
change the way you treat the patient that I guess maybe you should do the test
as long as you wait out the pros and cons of doing that procedure.
So a test, like a blood test,
well, there's not really any cons of doing that procedure,
unless you just throw that person away with emotional tizzy,
but you're doing something invasive.
You better have strong enough reason why to do that,
if you're going to do something invasive.
So I have had some patients come to me,
thinking that they have cancer,
that there are family members of somebody that is close to me or a patient,
and they're like, they're already into this whole alternative scene.
They're like, I am not even doing that.
Even this brain cancer patient, he had an MRI,
apparently not invasive, right?
He was not going to let him do a biopsy.
They may have wanted to do a biopsy.
Well, my question was, well, if you're going to,
are you, if you did the biopsy, stick this together.
So I talked about through this.
If you do the biopsy, and they say,
yep, we want to do surgery,
chemotherapy, radiation, would you do it?
To?
Well, then why would you do the biopsy?
You know, so I didn't tell him what to do,
but we just reasoned together.
You understand?
If I said you do the biopsy,
is that going to make you do a surgery,
chemotherapy, or radiation, whatever the results are.
And if they said, well, yeah,
if they think that that's the right thing to do,
then I say, do the biopsy then?
Do you understand?
You can't, you can't change everybody over your perspective.
You just got to educate them and let them go with it.
Clinical evidence of for parisurgical tumor recurrence
at incision site and remote locations.
Oh, what was it?
Oh, who was it?
I don't, it wasn't a patient, but I talked to somebody
of the phone.
I think it was a doctor who...
Cancer patient had a uterine cancer.
I think it was.
Had the uterus removed.
Now they have a tumor right where the uterus was.
Five, seven years later, something like that.
How was that?
Think of that.
How does that work?
They took the tissue out.
The tissue is gone.
Now, X amount of years later, they have a cancerous growth
right where that tissue was.
Does that make you think of things like,
wow, that's really cool stuff, really, for one perspective.
What is it, is it more than just the tissue problem,
or is it an electromagnetic issue with that person's body?
Talk about the acupuncture system and the meridians.
They took the tissue out.
There's the cancer.
They got it out.
Five years later, they got another tumor right where that uterus was.
That's this weird stuff.
There's more to it than just the physical, you know what I'm saying?
It's important stuff.
If you ever hear a new German medicine,
you heard of that?
Interesting stuff.
Dr. Humber, he's a German...
I don't think he's an oncologist.
He's an MD.
He treats cancer patients.
Been a while since I studied it.
He believes that all cancer is an emotional basis.
All cancer is the emotional basis.
First of all, you got to know my opinion.
Whatever somebody says, all cancer is this...
I think they're wrong.
Because there's never all of anything.
So there's all sorts of different causes for this.
That's what it...
Go back to what I said to Humber Humber.
Don't be dogmatic.
You know, there's...
Cancer can be caused through a fungus.
Dr. C. Majini believes all cancers cause through a fungus from Candida.
What's not?
You know, all cancers cause from...
from past emotional injuries.
No, it's not.
Can it all...
Can many of them be tied to that?
Sure.
But never is all of anything.
However, there's a lot of truths to be gleaned from a lot of these guys.
So is there an emotional basis to cancer?
Well, it certainly is an emotional tie to everybody that's got any sectors.
Because your emotions are integral part of your bead.
But can...
Ager hidden frustration.
Can it be an issue with cancer?
Yes.
Dr. Carolyn Macy.
Have you ever read any of her stuff?
She talks a lot about female issues.
Women that have the incidence of breast cancer.
Women that have been emotionally or sexually abused is literally like...
I don't know, five to ten times higher.
Her theory is that your breasts are something you give to your baby.
Your breasts are something you give to your husband.
And that emotional, physical, sexual abuse, women that have been raped
is something that's torn away from them.
And that emotional center is there.
That's pretty cool, interesting work.
There's definitely a tie with all this.
And you got to deal with this with your patients too.
So how do you deal with the emotional part with your patients?
I think a huge part of that is just developing that relationship with people.
I teach a lot of classes on just detoxification.
So one of the things that I really how down is,
okay, your body has two different ways that you get rid of things.
You kill it, or you detoxify it.
That's the only way.
And remember, you are what you eat.
You are more what you absorb, but you're really what you don't detoxify.
So if you're not getting rid of things either by killing them,
or by detoxifying them, they are becoming you.
They're settling somewhere.
And you'll have toxins, metals, chemicals, pesticides, fertilizers, everything,
settle where.
They settle typically in your fat cells.
Fat cells where.
That are the most vascular, which is where, around your organs.
So you got these chemicals settling in the fat cells
that have the gift of accommodation, invite everybody in, and they store things.
And that's, you're loaded with toxins.
You can't argue that.
People don't argue that anymore.
You just teach this 20 years ago, they're like,
well, I don't think so.
I only, three times a week.
And you know, now people don't argue that fact.
And you go into, that's what causes the sets up this immune issue.
You get any hyper-immune function for any reason, even a natural reason,
to kill off a virus, or bacteria, or flu bug, or a spray daco in your foot, whatever.
You're going to have the circulating cytokines that are simply looking for a war.
They're looking for somebody to fight.
And they're going to fight things where you don't want.
Oh, you got pesticides in your prostate, Quaid.
Oh, well, let's kill that.
It's not supposed to be there.
So it starts an attack on that.
And once your immune system turns out to attack, they are like vicious,
brain, US brain, they're not going to quit until they're called off.
And they don't get called off until they win the battle.
And they're never going to win that battle because that they can't die.
And now you're in trouble.
So now you got an autoimmune disease.
Set up.
And you got this constant inflammatory process.
Cells can't get their nutrition.
They have to start learning how to function and survive in an anaerobic environment.
So they start reproducing anaerobically.
Feed it off a glucose that can get into the cell structure.
That's what we call cancer.
So how are you going to fix this?
Are we going to just radiate it?
Keep out therapy it?
Cut it out?
You still don't have the environment there, right, for cancer?
Why did it start in the first place?
It's just going to grow back.
So you got to start at the beginning.
So you got to fix the autoimmune issue.
You got a balanced immune system.
When you're talking about cancer, they're like this TH2 dominant.
You have to give a lot of TH1 stimulants.
Really important.
You got to fix their stomach.
You got to fix their gut.
You have to fix those things.
They have anemia.
If they have a cancer coming into you, stage three, stage four, they got anemia of chronic disease.
You got to correct that.
Guarantee you the doctor hasn't addressed that at all.
Or they say, take ferrous sulfate.
So the person's in your office with Walgreens ferrous sulfate.
They can't figure out why they got such gut pain and digestion issues.
Because of course it's just elemental iron.
It's damaging their gut.
It's not helping them at all.
They can't figure out why their blood levels don't change.
So you got to fix that.
So what do you use for that?
What nutrition do you use?
What's going to that?
So with iron deficiency, anemia, due to chronic disease, I use ferro food.
If the person isn't, I take all cancer patients off of gluten.
Ferro food by standard process has some gluten in it.
But if they're not gluten sensitive because I test them out, then I'll use ferro food.
Even though I still take them off, why?
Because gluten is very pro-inflammatory.
We don't need any more inflammation of this person's body.
We don't need their immune system to try to deal with bad food.
So I use ferro food.
It's a great product for iron.
If they are gluten intolerant too, then I'll use standard processes liquid.
So ferro, what's it called?
Forgot what it's called.
So it's many herbs, liquid, layered.
And it doesn't have gluten in it.
Okay?
B12 deficiency, anemia.
Quite possible.
You have to use sublingual B12 with that.
A folic acid anemia.
You got to deal with that.
You see that a lot with kids or patients.
You got to fix their gut.
All I said with fixing their gut, you can't use glutamine.
Can't use glutamine with cancer patients.
So you got to figure out some other way to fix their gut.
So GI restores, a great way to fix their gut.
You see PRPs, a great way to fix their gut.
Any other deficiencies, nutritional deficiencies they might have.
You got to deal with that.
So any zinc deficiencies that they might have,
a lot of mineral deficiencies that are possible.
Any other metabolic blockages.
So we're talking about every one of these people
have blocked detox pathways.
I have heard it said that if all you did is alkalize the body,
then the cancer wouldn't be able to live,
because cancer can't live in an alkaline environment.
Right?
So there's some truth to that.
But there's a lot of untrue to that.
So I want to just, let's just, let's just bury this one right now.
Okay.
Even some doctors I know give sodium bicarb orally.
In a sense, there's some benefit to that.
If you give it in a couple doses concentrated orally,
because you will get some absorb should across the gut wall
that can help alkalize the tissue.
But there's a lot out there.
I have patients.
Maybe you don't.
But I have patients come in.
They already bought these keegan water systems and stuff
for their alkalizing, their water.
Let's just think about that from a physiological standpoint for a second.
Your stomach needs to be acidic.
Okay?
For the reasons that we read over and you guys already know.
So if you alkalize your first line of defense,
it's not even smart for a physiological standpoint.
You don't want to alkalize the stomach.
You want to alkalize the tissue.
That's why doctors see my cheating.
You know, doesn't give sodium bicarb orally.
He ejects it into the cancer.
And honestly, if I could do that legally,
I might do that on some cancers.
Because it makes sense to me.
So these things kind of make sense to you.
So you think these things through physiologically.
You don't alkalize the stomach acid.
They're by alkalizing the tissue.
You know, it's not.
This thing is alkaline.
Therefore, it's going to alkalize my tissue.
So I'm going to eat it.
No, it's what that does in your body.
So a lemon is a lemon acidic or alkaline.
Sytic, right?
But it alkalizes your tissue.
You understand?
Because I'm going to alkalize my water with this device.
Oh, it's a pH of 8.3.
Somehow, no, that's going to alkalize my tissue.
It's just ridiculous.
It's going to alkalize my stomach causing more digestive problems.
So I am totally against this alkalization of water.
Cut a stuff.
You alkalize your tissue by the food you eat that is alkalizing
that is alkalizing your tissues.
That it's in the right.
You alkalize your tissue because the food that you eat
helps change the pH balance of the extracellular spaces.
What is that?
Vegetables.
That's the whole benefit of the Gerson program.
It's a whole benefit of juice seed.
That's when alkalizing your tissue.
It's not because if I did a pH strip in my veggie juice,
oh, look, it's alkaline.
I don't know.
It's probably acidic.
Especially if you put a lot of apple in there.
It has nothing to do with the pH of that stuff.
You understand?
And to measure the pH of the urine say, oh, look,
no, I'm alkaline.
No, your urine's alkaline.
It means you're probably peon-calcy amount.
I don't know.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
Your body has buffer systems.
Your blood is always going to stay 7.3, 4, 5, or whatever it is.
Or you'll be dead.
You have buffer.
Your buffer systems go, you're dead.
That's part of what death is.
You lose all your buffered systems.
But what you want to alkalize is that extracellular maloo
around the cancer.
Cancer is acidic because it's rapidly replicated
and the simple act of replication of cell gives off waste
and the waste is acidic and it forms a acidic slime layer
around the cancer.
And the more rapidly it's replicated,
the more acidic slime layer you're going to have.
And that acts like a wall for your TH1 cytokines.
It can't penetrate it.
Right?
So you don't, you have to alkalize that cancer.
And you do that through juiced.
Right?
Adding lemon to your water is beneficial too.
Long-term, adding lemon to your water, you've got to be careful
because this person's suckered a lemon water.
It's not really good for their dabbled and their teeth though.
So you've got an AI patient.
I drop him down to only doing that every one three days or four days
or something like that after a certain point.
So with me, so you don't alkalize the water.
You alkalize the tissue and you do that through juiced
and things like that.
And through the nutrients that you give them.
And through opening up their detox pathways.
Because that's what makes them acidic.
Because they're holding all these poisons.
So all these other things you're doing, including the rife,
helps alkalize your tissue.
One of the theories of the rife is that that photon on the light,
you know, frequency, the light beam that's going through you,
acts as an electrode donor.
What's an electrode donation do?
It raises the pH.
That's another theory of one of the main reasons why rife works.
It raises the pH of the bluer of the cancer.
When it comes to toxicity too, you know, my other point is that
lots of times you're better off leaving sleepy giants lie.
You are toxic.
Your purpose is not to get all the poisons out of your fat cells.
You're never going to happen.
It's a fallacy.
You're full of yourself.
What you want to do is you want to get rid of the antigen.
So if my immune system is turned on against mercury,
I want to get rid of mercury.
I'm not going to try to pull, you do something that's going to pull
everything and do this radical detox.
That's why I'm not forward.
You would radical fasts and stuff like that that's going to just
throw your body into a tizzy.
So you want to be as specific as possible.
You can't be super specific all the time,
but you want to be as specific as possible.
If you're dealing with a biotoxid,
you're living an organism, right?
So they have, you know, chlamydia pneumonia.
So how are you going to kill that?
Well, you've got to figure out how you're going to kill that.
You don't want to do chelation.
You know what I'm saying?
So you want to know that they're dealing with the biotoxid.
Do I use clarified all the time?
Uh, somewhat.
I use clarified for me all the time because I'm addicted to it.
So chocolate clear bite mixed up in my little blender
with some ice and yesterday's coffee.
It's really good.
It's like a frappuccino.
Yeah.
So not really.
There's some general detox that are beneficial for liver pathways
in there, but it's not like,
pull it a whole bunch of stuff or anything like that.
So I think you're safe doing clear bite with anybody.
It's just a real nice gentle detox.
So it's not that really super specific or anything.
So I think clear bite.
We use a lot of clear bite.
Our patients like it.
I love it.
So.
But you understand what I'm saying about that?
I think the more specific you can get on what the antigen is
in an autoimmune issue,
I think the more success you're going to have.
And I tell you, sometimes it's like bouncing your hand against the wall
because you think you got it.
Here's a common scenario in my office.
Oh, we're dealing with, let's say they come up.
I'm doing a case.
Come up.
Primarily burkery.
Yeah.
Well, burkery.
That's definitely a base bottom thing.
We start treating them to get a little better.
And they just crash.
Crap.
Or they just level out.
What is it?
And they come up.
Lime.
In our area here.
Oh, crap.
I hate lime.
I'd rather have cancer for cancer patients than lime.
Because lime, if it's TH1 dominant, how do you kill it?
You kill a biotoxin.
You have to stimulate the TH1 system.
Because they have a biotoxin that's TH1 dominant autoimmune.
You can't give too much TH1 stimulators.
You're going to make them worse.
So side note.
One side note on TH1 dominant autoimmune issues.
MMS.
It's great.
Not MMS.
MMS.
It's a great tool.
I'll show it to you later.
But it's a great little thing.
You guys use that?
No.
Do you use that?
Maybe.
Show it to you right now.
Can you grab that over there, Dustin?
It's on the first shelf.
MMS.
It's on about four shelves right there.
You guys all should be using this.
A friend of mine in the cancer program, actually.
All he does, he's an MD.
I wanted Delaware, I think.
All he does is treat lime patients.
It's all he does.
And he's talking to a great guy.
You can so use an MMS for your lime patients.
What's that?
So same thing.
Because you guys, so oceans lab.
I think you should look this up.
Oceans lab.
It's actually you get a bottle of this.
And another bottle that's over there that looks exactly the same.
It's got a blue label.
And you have to activate it by mixing them together.
And sodium chloride or something, something like that.
It smells just like chlorine.
So, how you use it is, you try to kill any biotoxid.
It works really good.
So, how I tell a patient to use it, I take a spool out,
send it out of the table.
Put equal amounts, one drop of this to one drop of this.
And then you just let it sit there.
And it starts to turn yellow and bubble a little bit.
And I have a patient's spell that smells just like chlorine.
You have to let it activate for three minutes.
You'll get instructions at all this.
If you buy this stuff, super cheap.
It's $20 a set for the patient cost.
And then you put it in water.
And you let that activate in the water for 10 minutes.
And then you drink it.
I have to start with one drop, one drop of each.
Then I have to go one drop of each of the afternoon.
Then you go two drops, two drops.
Then I used to do a protocol like that.
Tight trade up, then tight trade down, like that.
And that worked okay.
Then I got to do a protocol of just randomly random.
And that's worked the best.
So do three drops of each.
You always do equal amount.
So three drops of the morning, four drops of the afternoon.
Then tomorrow, do four drops at 11 and three drops at 5.
And then you just get random, random, random, random.
That's been the best for Lyme disease besides the rife.
And the negative thing about the rife with Lyme disease
is you got to use it all the time.
We had word gal.
She had Lyme disease.
So bad.
It's just destroyed her life.
She used to be a triathlete, marathon runner.
She, 15 years, just completely, she's been everywhere, everywhere.
We started her out.
She was coming in here a couple of times a week, doing the rife.
She did a little better.
She plateaued off.
We're doing all this other stuff.
It's not the only thing we're doing all this other stuff.
A little bit better plateau.
All right.
Let's just do this.
We're just going to have you commit every day because she's not working.
I just want to get better.
Came in every day and I tell you she just bounced right up.
We're going to do two hour protocols.
So, actually, she's just going to get a rife at home.
I do a protocol.
You got Lyme disease.
You got to have your other distance program.
It's got to do it all the time.
But this is one thing that doesn't stimulate a TH1 response
and kills bio toxins.
That Laura Cinnon is another thing.
We just started using that so I can't give you any test abilities on that.
But a lot of testimonies on the board about the Laura Cinnon.
That's great for bio toxins as well.
You Google cancer alternative cancer therapies and such.
And one is Dr. Gonzalez's treatment.
That's the next slide here.
But Dr. Gonzalez's treatment really stems off of Dr. Kelly's work.
And Dr. Kelly's work really stems off Dr. Bard's work of the turn of the 19th century.
And Dr. Bard did some cancer research where he discovered using proteolytic enzymes
as a treatment cure for cancer.
Here, Dr. Cinnon, I have that chair up here.
And Dr. Kelly was an orthodontist in Dallas,
a Dallas suburb, I believe, and he developed cancer, liver cancer.
And it was so bad that it was bulging out of his side.
And he went to, he belonged to a big church.
Those big, mega churches down in Dallas.
Went to some of the doctors that he were down there,
that were his good friends.
And they basically didn't have any solutions for him.
I believe it was in the early 50s,
by the time frames off a little bit.
So he didn't know what to do.
And he was a very intelligent guy.
That was before the internet.
So he went to the medical library and started studying.
He found a book by Dr. Bard about treating cancer with enzymes therapy.
So he also got a hold of Dr. Gerson's information.
So he put together a program for himself,
where he used high dose enzymes therapy,
and he did juiced and coffee enemas.
And he got better.
And one of the other things that Dr. Bard did is
he put what I think what he got from Dr. Bard and Dr. Gerson,
he went completely off of meat.
So he got better.
And he could visually see his cancer going down.
And then if he ate meat, or he went off his diet,
or he didn't juice, or he didn't take his enzymes,
literally in a day, he could see the cancer getting bigger.
So for him, it was miraculous so he could judge his progress.
To talk about how do you judge somebody's progress?
How do you know if you're getting a person better?
Well, for him, it just happened to be that he could actually see the inflammation in his liver.
It wasn't the cancer in his liver getting that big and small over time.
It was inflammation in his liver going up and down.
He could literally see it.
Well, it was an amazing recovery, right?
And so a lot of the doctors in his church were like,
hey, I'm going to send you this patient.
And could you just do, oh, the nutritional stuff was like brand new.
And could you just do a nutritional consult on him?
And he put everybody on the exact same protocol.
You go completely meat free.
You do juicing.
You do coffee, animals, and you go on these enzymes.
And a number of people got better.
And as the story goes, however many people into this,
20 people into it, or whatever,
this young girl came to him with terminal cancer.
And he put her on the same diet.
And in a couple of weeks, she just tumbled and got like worse.
So then he had to go back to the droid board and figure out what is wrong?
What did I do wrong?
I can't lose this patient because I know it's supposed to be three of these people.
I'm in Northern Honest.
And so he went back to the droid board trying to figure out what to do differently.
And he uncovered some other information that he is now called metabolic typing.
So we're going to cover metabolic typing.
And he discovered that some people are either sympathetic dominant.
Some people are parasympathetic dominant and some people are mixed.
And then he over time separated into those three categories.
And then four categories within each three categories.
So there's like, who you talk to?
10 to 12 different types.
Some of these persons who is sympathetic dominant extreme, that's the person who can just never eat meat.
They can't eat any meat.
They probably would be better off going completely vegan to a person who is parasympathetic dominant extreme.
They should be eating meat every day, maybe three times a day.
And he theorized that the problem is, everybody in America is eating like their parasympathetic dominant extreme.
And that's part of the problem.
When most people are really in the mixed category, eating that we really should probably be eating meat, maybe three or four times a week in the mixed category.
And there's different balances in there.
So part of the way that you can determine this, and as the story goes, he put this girl on meat, and she just got better.
So everything else is the same.
Did the enzymes, did the coffee and amaz, did the juicing, but he had her sturdy eating meat.
And she just got better.
So that's what he got into the whole metabolic typing.
So Dr. Kelly lived with his cancer until the, that's what did he die?
The 70s or something like that.
And died like most of these guys, a completely broken man.
Because he treated Steve McQueen.
You remember who Steve McQueen was?
Well, Steve McQueen, like most Hollywood stars that get really sick, they go to the best and most expensive doctors.
And what that happens with them, I mean, he just tumbled down hill.
He was getting sicker, sicker, sicker, sicker.
His last ditch attempt to get better, when he was literally on his deathbed, he went to Dr. Kelly, who he never should have accepted this patient.
All right.
And he died within like three months, right?
Did Dr. Kelly kill him?
Of course not.
But the press at the time in the 70s, I believe it was, just had a heyday of this.
The alternative doctor killed Steve McQueen.
Dr. Kelly killed Steve McQueen.
I mean, they just, I mean, it was all out onslaught.
Front of people magazine, I don't know if they had people magazine back then, but it was, that was what it was.
I mean, it just, it just absolutely crushed him.
And he just, he just completely fell apart.
That, in fact, he destroyed a lot of his, I mean, he literally went off the deep end, destroyed a lot of his records.
And he had helped hundreds, hundreds of cancer patients up to that point.
Maybe thousands.
He just went off the deep end, forget everything.
Everybody's just crazy, and he just destroyed a lot of his records.
So a lot of his things that he, his way he analyzed metabolic typing is actually lost.
A guy who really picked up on his work was Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez.
Anybody heard of him?
He was featured in Suzanne Summers book, a cancer.
What was the name of that book?
It'll come to me in a second.
Something like that.
But he was one of my teachers at the A4M, seven hours.
I loved him.
Some of the other guys didn't like him.
He talks about the bile of it.
I just loved that.
He just ran, ran, ran, ran.
But, oh, that's Suzanne Summers book.
Actually, I told some guys at the class, or at dinner last night,
that Suzanne Summers was a guest speaker at last spring, last April's A4M conference.
I've never read any of her stuff before that.
I tell you, I have the absolute most respect for this lady.
She's very intelligent, and she is 100% on our side of the fence.
She does all natural stuff.
I understand also if you're going to do any A4M stuff,
they're hugely big into biomedical hormones.
So, you've got to, I know a lot about biomedical hormones just be going through their stuff,
but you can't legally do any of it except progesterone.
And I don't know what side of the fence I'm completely out of that.
But she's big into biomedical.
She is big into everything else that we do naturally.
She has a line of cosmetics and does some stuff like that.
When she found out that there was something in her line of cosmetics,
she pulled all of them.
She's very ethical in what she does.
She wants the best for any, you know, she's, she sticks to her ethics across the board.
But she was interviewed by date lighter 2020, about her book initially,
a year and a half ago.
You could probably Google it, it's probably on YouTube.
They promised her a fair interview with everything.
They cut and pasted and ripped her two pieces.
And she was just toured to shreds over that.
And so she'd never do another interview again.
Then somebody from date line, or 2020, I can't remember which one,
called her and begged her that they'd let her review the tape before and afterwards.
They did an interview with her just last summer at Eard.
And it was more fair, but you could tell there's still a little error in the voice about disbelief.
In that interview, they interviewed Dr. Gonzales.
They interviewed Dr. Brzynski.
They interviewed, I don't remember one of their doctors.
But I don't think they were fair to Dr. Gonzales.
You could tell they cut and pasted.
Dr. Gonzales is an extremely intelligent guy.
He did not start out as an alternative doctor.
He started out straight line medical research.
And also Dr. Mercola has about an hour-long interview with him
that you could Google and watch that interview.
I highly suggest you do that.
You'll see kind of the kind of guy he is.
He's very technical.
The only thing I don't like about his treatment protocol is that everybody fits into the same treatment protocol.
Just so you can grab that big bottle of enzymes up there.
So let's go over Dr. Gonzales' treatment protocol because I think there's something to learn from everybody.
Right next to the...
There you go, right there.
These are the enzymes that Dr. Gonzales uses.
So these are allergy research group with the company who makes them their pancreatic enzymes.
How he tests a person out for the nutrients that they need is that he does a hair sample that he sends to some lady in Arkansas that does some sort of like...
What's that technique where you rub the little thing?
What's that?
He does some sort of...
He's not even a doctor, some dumb sort of toughness.
I thought, Mike, he's yellow, he was weird.
This is a little bit weirder.
But that's how he determines the vitamins that they're on.
And then he puts people...
If you have a hard tumor, you're on 150 of these a day.
150 of these a day.
If you have a soft-sided tumor, you're on 75 a day.
Start off three weeks on one week off, then you're on two weeks on two weeks off.
Plus, a whole mess of supplements.
So a person...
He told me, because I talked to him after what he spoke.
He told me, he's interested.
He's talking to me, he's a little...
Standoff is talking to me.
He asked, kind of, Dr. I was.
I said, I'm a chiropractor.
Oh, you guys are the only guys that understand this stuff.
That's literally what he said.
And he said that he was real open with me.
And he said, yeah, people will be...
They pay that much up front and they'll be spending
on the average at least $700 a month in supplements.
This bottle is $180.
So it's a high amount of supplements that they're taking.
So into Gerson therapy again, because we touched on a lot of that last time
and then we'll take a break.
So again, Max Gerson, he's got this book and another book.
It's about that thick, good books to read.
If you want to really get into Gerson therapy,
that is their juicer right there that they really push.
It is the Noorwalk Juicer.
There, that name came to me.
It's about a $2,500 juicer.
And it's really a cold press juicer.
So you grind up the food in this thing right here.
And it comes out into kind of a bag, like a thing.
It's a cloth bag thing.
And you fold up the bag and you set it on that thing right there.
And this thing comes down with like a zillion pounds pressure
and it squeezes all the juice out of that food.
So it is truly cold press juice.
It's great.
It's fantastic.
It's super messy.
Sometimes the bag opens up, but it squirts all over your kitchen.
And it's kind of messy.
And it's expensive.
So it has some negatives just the juicer itself.
And when people go on Gerson's website and they've researched
a little bit or read his book, he is adamant about you
cannot use centrifugal juicers.
You have to use this cold press juicer.
Yes.
What brand is it?
Omega juicers.
Yes.
So let's go over some of the different juicers.
So let's first make a very strong statement that I made last time.
The new centrifugal juicers do not heat the food.
So they are fine to use.
But you don't get as much juice out of your vegetables.
So if you use a Jacqueline juicer, it's super cheap.
Max Curson today, if he was alive today,
I know that he would okay those juicers.
They do not heat the food.
The problem is you don't get as much juice out of the vegetables.
And if you're juicing in a Gerson method,
which is, if you're following the Gerson method to the tea,
you're drinking 13 glasses of juice a day.
Well, then you're vegetables.
You're spending a fortune by vegetables, right?
And so you do want to get more out of the vegetables.
So when I still suggest this juicer, no.
I would suggest the Omega juicer or the Champion juicer.
I like the Omega juicer better.
So the Omega juicer goes through this little thing and it kind of squashes it out.
It works really well.
It's easier to clean than the Champion juicer.
And you get more juice than from like the Jacqueline juicer.
However, not ever.
When you got a patient coming to you, they're in overwhelm.
So, just got to understand.
They're blown away.
They think they're going to die.
They're blown away with everything.
They got everybody giving them an opinion.
Everybody's telling them something to do.
And they're just like in total overwhelm.
And they're like, oh, so I try to keep it super, super simple.
So I say, do you have a juicer?
Yes.
What kind is it?
It's just one we got at Walmart.
Well, it's really a juicer.
Yes, it's really.
It's what a juicer.
Fine.
Use that.
Do you have a juicer?
No.
We don't have a juicer.
Okay.
You need to go buy a juicer.
You have a choice.
You want to go big and serious to get an Omega juicer and order it online.
And I actually have order offer Mercola's website.
Because that's where I found the best thing.
But I bet you could find it on Amazon and order it on Amazon.
They're like 300 bucks.
If that's too overwhelming, go to Walmart.
You know, some of these people, they've never ordered anything online before.
How do you do that?
I think our computer works.
I can ask my son, okay, stop.
Okay.
Just go to Walmart.
Buy a Jacqueline juicer.
Go to Coals and buy a Jacqueline juicer.
Or go to Walmart.
If some people come to me and they're like so strapped for cash.
And they came up with the money for the program.
They don't have any more money.
Go to Walmart and buy their, they have a $45 Jacqueline dock off.
Just use that.
Okay?
Because I'm not asking people to juice 13 times a day.
So I'm asking people to juice once a day.
And try to get like 24 ounces.
Try to get at least 16 ounces.
And drink that for the morning.
So how I tell them to start juicing is that I want you to start with carrot.
Apple salary is a base.
So that's your base.
Carrot, apple, celery.
And then you could add as many things as you buy.
So when you add beets, though, slice them like an apple.
You could even use an apple slicer, slice them up.
Just add a couple slices of beets.
Because beets are going to make your juice really red.
And they're going to make your pea red.
And they're going to make your poo red.
So you're going to think you're bleeding from the inside out your diet.
So don't call me.
You're not dying.
It's a purplish red.
And you can tell the difference.
But you add too much beet.
I mean, you'll really have like bright purplish red urine.
Like, it's amazing.
So, and then add kale.
Add, you know, go to the store by all organic.
It has to be organic.
So you don't juice conventional vegetables.
You juice organic.
And then you just add things to it.
So use that as a base and add things to it.
So, what?
Anything that they shouldn't be juiced in?
I don't know.
Really?
No.
What's that?
Gerson doesn't want spinach at all.
But I tell him to juice spinach too.
I think the majority of stuff you juice.
Some of the things that Gerson says that it's old thing have been overturned.
Understand.
What are my teachers at A4M?
I think I told you yesterday was actually the head of the Gerson clinic for 13 years.
And he just finally said, I can't do this anymore.
And they opened up their own clinic at Tijuana because he said,
Max would have changed these things for crying out loud.
So, again, that's where they get so dogmatic.
They stick to their guns on different things like that.
It's just ridiculous.
Yes.
Are you juiced only for your juiced for ever?
Oh, you mean, are you doing it as a meal substitution?
No, I wouldn't say it's a meal substitution.
But when you do juice and you have a big glass of juice, you're not eating as much.
So, I don't know how, if you were doing the Gerson diet,
honestly, that you would have time to eat anything else if you're drinking a glass of juice every hour.
I don't know how you'd be hungry for anything else.
So, the heart of the Gerson program is juicing and coffee animals.
And understand if you went to the Gerson clinic,
everybody would go completely vegetarian, which I totally disagree with.
Again, Dr. Kelly proved that everybody's different.
You can't have everybody go vegetarian.
So, doing the metabolic type aid is really important.
And you can find again a lot of that out, but just ask you them.
Have you ever eaten vegetarian?
Yeah, I did once years ago.
I felt best.
You know what, we're taking you off all meat.
Or when I do, too, if this person is way overweight,
and he needs, he's metabolic syndrome, he needs to lose weight.
Let's touch on that a little bit, because juicing is very high carbs.
So, it could spike their glucose levels.
So, in that diet, that cancer diet,
I think on the second page, it talks about counting your carbs.
If a person is cacacic, you know what that means?
Caxia is when they're just like frail and, you know, their cancer is basically,
is causing their muscles to be just burned into glucose so that it feeds their cancer.
So, whenever cancer feeds on glucose, so if they're just burning up their protein
in a gluconeogetic state to produce glucose so that it feeds their cancer,
that's what cacaxia is.
Somebody who's just wilted away, they need calories.
So, you know, the more juicing that you do, the better.
Well, that glucose is going to feed the cancer.
Well, I'd rather have the cancer feed off the glucose if it was so,
if you have the cancer feed off the glucose that you're putting in their wealth
and feed it off their own body tissue.
So, but it's really not feeding the cancer.
But if a person is diabetic or metabolic syndrome,
I make them really watch their carb count also.
So, you have to treat the whole person, not just the cancer.
You're not treating the cancer, you're treating the whole person.
This person may be part of why they got cancer is their metabolic syndrome or their diabetic.
So, I make them count their carbs in grams.
You guys know how to do all that, right?
So, I put anybody that's metabolic syndrome or if they don't have cancer
at a gram carb count.
So, I make them start at 75 grams of carbs.
Then we drop down to 50 grams of carbs per day,
and that you just count your carbs.
Do you have a list of these?
No, go to a just Google Carb Caltine.
There's some Adkins website that have carbs of protein of every single thing.
You got to write that out.
Anything that you eat that's processed, look at the back of it.
How many grams of carbs? How many grams of fiber?
You're going to track that out. That's your net grams of carbs.
You're going to count this out every day,
and you only have a bank account of 50 grams of carbs that you can eat per day.
So, besides the fact that even cancer patients,
you're taking them off of all gluten,
you're just decreased their total carb code dramatically right there.
Because that's where they're getting a lot of their carbs.
You're taking them off sugar and gluten.
I mean, you just completely drop their carb codes.
So, who cares how many carbs they're getting and their juice?
Right? So, you look at most people,
they're eating two, three hundred grams of carbs a day.
So, you're drastically reduced it.
When you take them off sugar and you're taking them off,
gluten and even most other grains.
So, on that diet, typically,
on a cancer patient, I'll make them go.
This is typically. I'll make them go pretty much gluten-free, dairy-free.
They're cutting down their meat, their fish, and they're chicken.
All of them are cutting down.
And some people make them go completely off.
Does that make sense on that?
So, that's why I call it a modified gerson program
because we drastically modify it.
Yes?
How do you mix the juicing with the formulated fast?
No, they're totally separate.
Juicing and formulated fast are completely separate.
No, the formulated fast, you're sipping all day long.
Sorry.
So, in your packet as an example of a formulated fast
and how it's explained, it says this isn't really a fast.
It's just a research or a metabolic system and help clean you out,
to help nutritionally feed you throughout the day.
You're sipping all day long on this jug of water.
So, that 32-oz shaker bottle that they're putting,
whatever stuff I haven't put in there, they're sipping all day long.
So, that's, I think, the major benefit of it is that they're infusing
this nutrition all day long.
That's completely separate than they're juicing.
When you juice something, can you save it for the whole day?
Well, no, technically, you're supposed to drink it right away.
However, I do a modified approach.
So, I have them, if you could juice, you know, they're busy
and they're still working, how are they going to do this?
So, I have them juice, get up a half hour early,
juice in the morning, had juice try to juice up to 24 ounces
and then put it in a jar or something that has a tight cover
and keep it well refrigerated and drink that all day long too.
And then you can clean your juicer,
because that's the biggest complaint about juicing.
It's a pain in the butt.
So, it's just very time consuming, cleaning that stupid thing, et cetera.
So, you got to really emphasize the benefits of juicing
and what it's going to do for that person so that they'll do it.
And minimize the effort, and that's why I have them just do it once a day.
Now, if they're willing to do it, some people are retired, they're not working.
They're willing to, can we do it more?
Yes, the more you do it, the better. That's great.
So, it's individual on that part.
I do not want their cure to consume them.
I just think that that's not right.
You know, you get what you put your mind on all the time.
And it's not all you're thinking about. It's your cancer all the time.
That's not a good thing. It's not a good thing just for the healing process.
So, like I said yesterday, why live?
If that's all you're consumed with, it's just your cancer.
So, I want people to, that's what I like about the life at home.
They're doing it at night. They're sleeping. They're going to sleep anyhow.
They're sleeping with the thing. They're waking up.
They're going, they're living their life.
That's hugely important to me.
I mean, we spent, as a family, a year being a missionary down in Mexico.
That was a great thing to do for our kids.
You know, just have to see the other world.
Live it in cardboard boxes and, you know, homemade little shelters
and eating cookie at a little, you know, fire outside their cardboard box
and having sewage run down the middle of the street.
And you get a completely different perspective of life like that.
I think that's valuable.
For years after we came back in 98 and I went back to practice,
we'd take short-term mission trips down with patients.
Did that five times. We went down every couple of years.
I haven't done it for a number of years though.
They're thinking about getting back to that. I just don't have time to do that right now.
But it was valuable. We'd take a group of patients down there and see what it's like.
We'd go down to Mexico and go across the border.
I worked with one of the poor people's hospital.
Brought them in here. Here's the poor people's hospital.
Yeah, they'd give you a room.
But if you needed anything, you had to go pay for a pharmacy across the street
and bring the drug back.
You go in there and pray for these people.
And there's like part of a liver laying on the floor.
It's just unbelievable and filthy.
And these people are dying. They are gangrenous and all this stuff.
And you get a totally different perspective of life.
And all of a sudden, hey, you know what? I guess I'm not so mad.
And it's very important in my book that these people do everything they can to take their mind off of their cancer.
So I don't want their cure to consume them as well.
So I try to get them juicing once a day, do it right in the morning, clean the juicer, go live your life.
You're doing the right all night long. It's just the right thing to do.
It doesn't mean you don't do the right things, but you don't have the right things take up your life.
So any other questions? Oh, a little more about Gerson.
Gerson's typical protocol is you do five coffee and a buzz a day.
To me, again, that's like, are you kidding?
How are you going to do five coffee and a buzz a day? It works still.
You know, not everybody can just like quit life and do this.
So, and again, I think I hammered that home that I don't believe that that's valuable.
So if a person who does one coffee in a day, we're winning.
So that's all I ask them to do.
That's the picture of the Jack LaLade juicer.
It works fine. If you're juicing once a day, it's fine.
100 bucks, 112 dollars at coals, you know?
Why we recommend doing the coffee enemas? It's because it's really a great liver detox.
So, even though I know people think it's for the colon, it helps the colon, but it's a great liver detox.
So what happens is the caffeine gets absorbed by the hemorrhagic veins.
And that is carried via the portal system to the liver and to the gallbladder,
which helps the bile ducts open up and dumps the bile, which has a lot of toxins,
and especially with your cancer. It really, anybody, because we've all got a lot of toxins,
but especially if you have cancer, it will build up there.
So this is helping to clean out the liver in the gallbladder because it's dumping the bile.
And the other thing that it does, the palmitic acid salts that are in the coffee,
they help to increase the body's production of glutathione S-transferase by up to 700%.
So, and they've got, in those books, they've got references to the studies that they've done.
Actually, Gerson didn't do those studies, somebody else did, so there's references to them.
And so, that alone is a huge detoxifier. That's one of the biggest reasons why it works so well.
When you buy these things, it comes with, this is the vaginal tip, so we don't use that.
This one right here is the rectil.
So it has a large opening at the end. There's a clip on the universe.
This is just a stop, stopper for the bag, if you were just using it like a hot water bottle.
And then this one has the opening for the tube.
And there's also a little stopcock.
Plus a 10-year warranty on the peg, which you think.
Well, I bet they get a lot of returns on those bags, I don't know.
So you just put the stopcock on first so that you can slide it in there.
Stretch out the tube, because the tube gets all bent over and kinked, so you kind of stretch it out before you start.
Put on the stopcock, which then just works, you know, like that, to close it off when you fill it up.
Okay, push that down.
Put this little thing on the edge. It's really easy.
Okay, so that's it. That's ready to go.
Then you're going to just pour the coffee in here.
And I'll explain how you make it and everything.
Close it up, and I will actually take it in the sink and hold it upside down and let it fill the tube and then close this off.
So that it's all full already and it's not like you're putting a lot of air in.
And then there's a little hook here that you can put through the edge of this bag.
And you can hang it on the tall rack or on the door handle or something in your bathroom.
You're going to want to be close to the toilet.
So this is how we instruct people to make the coffee for the coffee animals, which is the same recipe that they do use for the person therapy.
So you take, and this is where I brought props.
You take a quart.
And that's a large amount, you know, but it is important that you have a quart of water.
And it's either distilled water or filtered water.
You know, you don't want to be putting in the chlorine and fluoride into your body, especially when you're that sick already.
So they actually recommend distilled at home. I have a reverse osmosis unit on the kitchen sink.
So then what you do is just, I'm pouring that into my saucepan on the stove.
It's not like making coffee in a coffee maker.
So you're putting in the saucepan on the stove.
You put in three tablespoons of organic coffee, and it has to be organic.
That's really important because coffee is a very highly sprayed crop.
So three tablespoons of coffee, and you boil it on the stove for three minutes, and then you simmer for 15.
Then you just let it cool down to body temperature.
So then when I'm done with that, I take the cooled down coffee.
I actually do it hot and let it cool down in here.
And then pour it through this strainer.
So you can see it's not a coffee filter.
It's just a regular strainer, and it doesn't go real well through a coffee filter.
It actually would just take a very long time.
We've had people who have tried that. It doesn't work that well.
And you do want the silt.
You don't want the grounds, but you want the silt that comes with the coffee.
Because some of those acids and things are caught up in that silt.
So then once it's cool, you're pouring it into the bag.
Ready to get started.
So then what you do is you go down in the bathroom, and you're going to try to make yourself comfortable,
putting towels or something down on the floor to lay on, and something washable, and you're going to lay on your right side.
And it's important that you lay on your right side.
Because even though it seems like the opposite for if you were going to do a colon cleanse,
you would lay on your left side.
But you lay on your right side because that's where those hemorrhagic veins are.
So the caffeine is more easily absorbed through those veins if you lay on your right side.
So that's why that's recommended.
If you have people who can't do that, you know, because they're injured in some way,
it's affecting their bones.
What the Gerson therapy recommends is that you lay on your back then if possible.
But try not to do the left side.
It just doesn't work as well.
So really rights preferred.
So then you lay on your right side.
You can use the stopcock to slow it down or let it all go through as quickly as possible.
But you want to hang the bag no more than 18 inches above your body because it's gravity fed.
So, you know, the higher it is, the faster it's going to go in and it could cause cramping.
So you want to slow it down if it's causing cramping so that it goes in more easily.
And then what you do is hold it in for 12 to 15 minutes.
And which is very difficult for people especially at first.
Because your body's just not used to that and you're going to feel like you want to get up and go right away.
It does really increase the peristolic motion.
So you're going to, you know, they're going to feel it.
So I think when I started doing it, I could only do six minutes at first.
That's fine.
Just anything.
Just to get started.
And you'll work your way up to it.
You get used to it after a while.
So then you can do 12 to 15 minutes.
And the reason that they say that is they actually describe this as a dialysis for the blood.
Because every three minutes, all the blood in your body is going through the liver.
So when you've got that caffeine in there and it's making this extra glutathione,
they're saying that, you know, the blood is getting cleaned out every three minutes.
So that if you have the coffee being held in from 12 to 15 minutes,
then it's going to get four to five times of a cycle with your blood going through.
There's laying on the bathroom floor.
Yep.
You're timing it.
You're just laying there for 12 to 15 minutes.
And then you're done.
Then you get up.
Yep.
Get up.
Go on the toilet.
Get rid of it.
And clean out all the stuff.
Yes.
So it doesn't matter if it's already ground.
You can buy it ground or in the beans and then just grind it.
But it must be ground coffee.
It's ground coffee, yeah.
They have it inserted.
Yep.
If they like low ends, they want to try to empty the whole bag into them.
The whole bag.
And you want it?
And the other thing I forgot to mention, it's really important.
You know, some of the water is going to boil off.
You want to add enough water back into that to make a quart.
It needs to be a quart that goes in here.
So they're just laying there with a still all attached.
Yep.
Just leave it attached.
One of the things that it talks about, especially in a little animal book,
is people were running into where, well, it doesn't go in.
How come it's not going in?
Well, something's in the way.
You know, it's either gas or a stool or something's in the way.
So you can open this up, just leave it open.
Gas can go back up into the bag.
You can just slow it down.
You know, people need to relax.
It does make them nervous, especially at first.
And that does make it harder to do.
So you have to just start doing it.
And then they'll relax, realizing it's not going to hurt.
You know, because that's their fear.
You can use some kind of a lubricant.
I mean, just olive oil or anything.
It also will make it easier for your body to push it out.
That's the drawback.
That's the drawback, but sometimes people need it.
So you don't want to injure yourself when you put it in.
Yep.
Sometimes you're not able to control it.
So you've got to have washable things on the floor.
So, other things that stimulate liver detoxification.
What would be castor oil packs?
Ever hear of that?
So you just go buy castor oil.
You could buy it on Amazon.
PRL sells some castor oil too.
I think you'd buy it on Amazon for cheaper.
I tell people to get a little tougherware thing that's like square.
And on Amazon also, you could buy this wool fleece, wool flannel.
It's called.
And they have some disposable wool flannel.
Old days, they used to use wool flannel,
and they just used it over and over and over again.
I don't know if that's a great idea.
So they have disposable wool flannel that you just cut pieces,
the size of the area that you're going to treat.
You can do castor oil packs on anything, any part of your body.
Good to do them over the liver.
Pour the castor oil into this little tray.
It's actually just a tougherware tray so you could just cover it up
and you can save it.
And then you put the fleece in there, ring it out.
So you're going to kind of piece six by six to go over the liver.
Ring it out pretty good.
And you're going to put it over the liver.
However, it's very messy.
It's castor oil.
So I tell people to put a big piece of plastic or a plastic bag on their bed.
And then put a towel over the bag.
To get this ready, and you laid out,
this piece of castor oil right over your liver area.
I show people where to put it.
Then put it like a plastic bag or some plastic wrap.
But that doesn't work.
It all sticks together and stuff.
So put a wall art bag over that and put a hot pack over that.
So they're heating that up and just kind of heating it into their body.
And it just helps their liver flush.
You could do castor oil packs over any part of your body, if you would.
So that just helps you detox.
You don't know a lot about dental stuff.
You should probably Google another term, dangers of root canals.
That'll scare the daylights out of you.
There's one in Ananas that wrote a whole series of articles that he published on the website
for everybody to know about root canals.
You'll never have another root canal in your life.
What do you do this?
What do they do with the root canal?
They go and they dig out all the root, all the nerve, and they fill it up.
So now you don't have any pain in that tooth.
Will you still have this porous substance that now doesn't have any blood supply or nerve supply?
What is that?
It's like a apartment complex for bacteria.
And they can live in there and never be touched.
You could take antibiotics forever and you're never going to get at it
because there's no blood supply in that tooth.
So it's never going to circulate the antibiotic because it's never going to get into that tooth.
So this is just giving off this constant, some clinical infection to this person for the rest of their life.
And causing all of their sickness.
A little word about getting your mercury fillings done.
I think we put that on the board.
Somebody asked me that yesterday.
You have to do it right.
You just don't go to a regular dentist and have them take out all your mercury fillings.
You're going to kill that person.
So you've got to do it right.
You've got to put a rubber dam in.
You've got to go to somebody who a dentist who knows how to do this.
Put a rubber dam in on each tooth.
Most dentists don't like to do that because they kind of put that stupid thing on the tooth with the rubber thing.
And it's like a technique to be able to do that well.
Takes 10 minutes to do that.
Dentists are paid by time.
And then they put that rubber dam on.
And then they have to have a mercury vacuum.
They don't even own one of those.
You're done.
And then they're going to put something over your nose.
Hopefully a nasal cannula or at least a wet washcloth over your nose while they drill this thing out and get it out of you.
If they don't do that, you're going to toxify the person.
Once you know something, I hate to tell you this.
You have a responsibility to do something with it.
So that's always been my philosophy.
Once I know something, crap.
Wish I had no that.
Oh, I got to do something with it.
Ignorance is bliss sometimes.
Of course, it leads to death and misery.
But it can't be bliss.
So once you know something, now you've got to take care of people with this stuff.
I'm happy people with this stuff.